bienvenue au jardin du Luxembourg nous
sommes près de la fontaine Médicis au
cœur de ce grand espace de verdure à la
disposition des Parisiens et de ceux qui
sont le passage à Paris grand ou petit
c'est Marie de Médicis l'épouse d'Henri
IV et reine de France qu'il y a plus de
400 ans acheté au duc de Pinel
Luxembourg le terrain qu'occupe
aujourd'hui le jardin d'où son nom son
entretien et son animation sont assurés
par le Sénat dont le rôle principal est
de voter les lois et de contrôler le
gouvernement
348 sénateurs sièges tout près du jardin
au Palais du Luxembourg
le jardin du Luxembourg recèle des
trésors extraordinaires allons y faire
un tour ensemble
à l'écart des activités palpitantes du
Parlement c'est un lieu calme où les
visiteurs peuvent se promener jouer
faire du sport ou encore se cultiver
les enfants se balancent dans le petit
parc de jeux d'autres mangent une glace
les thés les joueurs de tennis ou de
pétanque sont nombreux
dès que le temps le permet des joueurs
d'échec se regroupent et il peut y en
avoir plus d'une centaine à certaines
heures TU SAIS cet endroit est très
connu dans le monde entier de grands
maîtres des échecs et même des étrangers
de passage viennent rejoindre les
joueurs habitués figurent bien connues
qui animent le jardin
allons désormais vers le kiosque à
musique beaucoup d'amateurs de concerts
de plein air s'y retrouvent au programme
divers style comme du jazz de la musique
classique de la country et même de la
musique de film qu'il est agréable
d'écouter des instruments avant et des
percussions sous les massifs fleuris
[Musique]
le musée du Luxembourg qui se trouve
dans le jardin présente également de
nombreuses expositions d'art que tu peux
venir admirer en famille il y a des
photographies des tableaux des
sculptures tiens tu entends ces rires
d'enfants ils viennent du théâtre de
marionnettes Guignols il fait des farces
et raconte ses blagues depuis des
générations et ce n'est pas tout le
jardin abrite aussi un verger avec des
pommiers des abricotiers des pruniers
des poiriers ce sont des espèces
anciennes qui donnent des fruits
délicieux ils sont cultivés sans
pesticides on coûte aujourd'hui presque
1000 arbres un peu plus loin des
abeilles bourdonnent elles font leur
miel dans des ruches
et je vais te dire un secret dans le
jardin il y a également une orangerie où
sont rangées en hiver de grands palmiers
et des orangers ils craignent le froid
et certains arbres sont plusieurs fois
centenaires il y a aussi une superbe
collection de plantes tropicales et
d'orchidées
ces plantes du monde entier se trouvent
tout au fond du jardin dans les serres
où il fait chaud et humide tous les
jours un des jardiniers donne à boire
aux plantes et les gueries quand elles
sont malades
ici les jardiniers sont plus de 70 à
tailler les arbres à tondre la pelouse
et à prendre soin des plantes grâce à
eux ce jardin qui est aussi grand que 34
terrains de foot est un endroit
merveilleux pour les armes les plantes
les fruits les animaux il a même été élu
plus beau jardin d'Europe
j'espère que cette visite t'a plu à
bientôt au jardin